THIS SAID. WE'LL BEGIN TO TWELVE
AGAIN TODAY'S HEARING- THIS WILL
BE A RELATIVELY BRIEF HEARING WE
THINK RELATED TO THE PART OF
EDUCATION. WE HAVE TWO ISSUES WE
HAVE A VOTE ONLY HER SECOND ITEM
ON SOME MISCELLANEOUS JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSALS. WE ALSO HAVE-
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS PROPOSAL FROM LAST
YEAR'S- BUDGET WELL SOME MINOR
ADJUSTMENTS FROM THE JANUARY
BUDGET FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS- SO
WE'LL START WITH THAT ISSUE
NUMBER ONE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WE
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE
HAVE ELADIO WE HAVE CD HE- AT
THE UCLA CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLING AND A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SISSIES COMMITTEE ON
HELLO. OKAY LET'S START WITH
CITY. I'M SORRY WE'LL START WITH
BERMAN FINANCE. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS PAUL FINISHER TANG
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I'LL HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE
TRAILER BILL AMENDMENTS PROPOSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM ESTABLISHED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACTS. THE INTENTION BEHIND THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IS NOT TO
CHANGE THE OVERALL PURPOSE OR
INTENT OF THE PROGRAM. BUT THE
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAILS TO
AREAS THAT NEED FURTHER
CLARIFICATION. STREAMLINE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES AND
REMOVE BARRIERS THAT HAVE BEEN-IDENTIFIED AS THE PROGRAM HS
BEGUN MOVING FORWARD WITH
IMPLEMENTATION. AND TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE MONITORING AND
EVALUATING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAM AT THE BEING ROLLED
OUT. NOTABLE CHANGES INCLUDE
ADDING CLARIFYING LANGUAGE TO
OPERATIONALIZE THE VISION AROUND
THE SERVICES COORDINATION
FUNDING. THE FUNDING ALLOCATION
FOR COORDINATION IS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT SUSTAINABILITY BY
HELPING SCHOOLS SECURE LONG TERM
FUNDING STREAMS AND COMMITMENTS
AND COORDINATE WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO SUPPORT ONGOING
PROGRAMMING. SCHOOL SHOULD BE
ENGAGING IN COORDINATION AND
SUSTAINABILITY WORK FROM THE
BEGINNING AS PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD.
INCORPORATING THE COORDINATION
GRANT AS PART OF IMPLEMENTATION
WILL STREAMLINE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE GRANTS AND
BEST SUPPORT A COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
LONG TERM SUCCESS. BY
EMPHASIZING THE NEED FOR A MULTI
AGENCY COORDINATION FROM DAY
ONE. BUILDING ON THE FOCUS OF
COURT ON COORDINATION WE
PROPOSED ALLOCATING SIXTY
MILLION OF THE EXISTING THREE
BILLION FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO HELP COORDINATE
SERVICES. PROGRAMS AND OTHER
RESOURCES BETWEEN COUNTY LEVEL
PARTNERS AND COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
IN THE REGION. A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF SERVICE COORDINATION
HAPPENS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
BETWEEN COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION HEALTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES. AS
WELL AS REGIONAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS FUNDING
WOULD BE FORMULA BASED WITH A
MINIMUM ALLOCATION OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND NO MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PER
YEAR PER OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CLARITY ON HOW QUALIFIED
ENTITIES CAN SPEND LOCAL GRANT
FUNDS. WE PROPOSE TO ALLOW
AUTHORITIES TO RETAIN UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. OR 10% OF THE
TOTAL WARD FOR IT SITES EACH
YEAR. TO SUPPORT ADMINISTRATION
OVERSIGHT AND COORDINATION OF
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. FINALLY WE
PROPOSE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
OVER FIVE YEARS FOR ANNUAL
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENTS TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRESS AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM.
MAKE CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENTS AND
SHARE BEST PRACTICES AND LESSONS
LEARNED FOR NEW GRANTEES THAT
COME ON BOARD. WE EXPECT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
WILL BE AN ERROR THAT PROCESS
AND THAT ADDITIONAL CHANGES MAY
BE NEEDED IN THE FUTURE AS WE
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM. RECEIVE FEEDBACK AND
ADDRESS ISSUES AS THEY EMERGE.
WITH THAT SAID THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AS A STARTING POINT FOR
CONVERSATION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON REFINING THE LANGUAGE TO FIND
THE BEST PATH FORWARD TO ENSURE
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS SUCCESSFUL.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU YOU'RE
NOT FROM THE L. A. L. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL FERRIS WITH THE ILLEGAL
WE HAVE NO SPECIFIC. CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSED CHANGES A
TROUBLING WITH FOR THE
COMMITTEES COULD NOT PROGRAM BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE PERFECT TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
BUT YOU'RE NOT FROM CITY. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING CHAIR-
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS STEVE
ZIMMER- DEBBIE SUPERINTENDENT-
THE STUDENTS SUPPORT- SERVICES
DIVISION BRANCH- CALIFORNIA. OF
EDUCATION. TODAY I'M TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND.
I'M HONORED TO REPRESENT THE
SUPERINTENDENT. PROUD TO SPEAK
OF OUR DEPARTMENT'S COMMITMENT.
TO IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM. THAT
MATCHES THE IDEALS AND VALUES.
THAT DROVE THIS BODY OUR
GOVERNOR TO MAKE THE LARGEST
INVESTMENT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. IN
OUR NATION. I'M GRATEFUL TO JOIN
OUR OUR COLLEAGUES FROM T.
YOU'RE OUT IN LA- TODAY. I'M
PUBLIC SIR ON THE PANEL WITH
DOCTOR CARE COURT FROM YOU. AND
ALSO IN YOUR SMOKE TOLERATE G.
FACT FFICER FELL THE US. ONE
REPORT TO YOU SCHOOL WAREHOUSE
NAME. I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
WORKING WITH CARRIE AND ALLISON
TO CREATE SOME GOOD SCHOOLS
TROUBLE UNLESS ANGELES. CD IS
GREAT FOR THE TO ADVANCE THE
IMPORTANT WORK. OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAN SCHOOLS PROGRAM.
WE KNOW THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL
STRONG COULD BE THE FACT
APPROACH. TO MIDDLE THE ACT AND
IMPACT. OBVIOUSLY THE DESPAIR.
THAT IMPACT SCHOOLS ARE. AND OUR
YEAH. THEY CAN ALSO IMPROVE
SCORES THE JUST AND FAMILY NEEDS
ORGANIZED SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY.
TO ADDRESS BARRIERS TO LEARNING
. IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE EMBRACED
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AS A
TRANSFORMATION SCHOOL
TRANSFORMATION MODEL. PUT SEEKS
TO TRANSFORM RELATIONSHIPS
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL LEGAL
SYSTEM IN WAYS THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY TRANSFORM OUTCOMES.
FOR STUDENTS WHO STRUGGLE THE
MOST THE SYSTEM THAT HAS NOT
ALWAYS OBEYED THEIR ASSETS. OR
SUPPORTED THEIR NEEDS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND INITIAL FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT
COMMUNITY SCHOOL SUPPORT THE
PILOT PROGRAM IN WHICH TURKEY
WHICH CVE FUNDED TWENTY GRANTEES
TO SUPPORT BY A HUNDRED TWENTY
SCHOOL SITES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
CD IS CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
WEST THAT ON THE VALUATION OF
THIS PROGRAM. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REPORTING BACK TO YOU
ABOUT THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE FIELD. WE'RE NOT HUMBLED TO
LEAD THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM. WHICH IS
THE LARGEST INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS IN THE NATION
. THREE BILLION DOLLARS THIS
THREE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. IT'S ONE
MOST POWERFUL ENDORSEMENTS OF
THE DREAMS OF OUR KIDS THE
ASSETS OF OUR FAMILIES. AND THE
PURPOSE OF PUBLIC EDUCATION. I
WITNESSED IN MY LAPTOP WE THANK
THIS COMMITTEE THE WHOLE THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
BELIEVING IN OUR STUDENTS THEIR
FAMILIES OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TRUSTING CD. TO
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM. I'M
JOINED TODAY BY P. CALLAS.
BROOKLYN WILLIAMS THE SENIOR
ADVISER TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
FROM YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE MOMENT
AND THE AND THE OR WHO IT'S OUR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS COORDINATOR I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU TO BREAK
ON THESE TO REIMERS WITHIN THE
CENTRAL PART OF THE STATE. I THE
TEAM HAS WORKED AND NIGHT. TO
GET US TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
STEPS- LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING WITH YOU TODAY. WE'VE
ALSO WORKING TRUE PARTNERSHIP
WITH STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION I
WANNA THANK WORK PRESIDENT LINDA
DARLING HAMMOND. BOOKS ALLEN AND
THE S. B. A. S. B. TEAM WALKED
JOURNEY WITH US EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY. AS I SPEAK TO YOU RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE JOINT TEAMS SCORING
AND CALIBRATING APPLICATIONS.
ARE AHEAD OF THE FRIDAY SB
POSTING UP ON. I DO BELIEVE WE
HAVE CAPTURED THE COOPER SPIRITS
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MOVEMENT. HAS
PROPELLED OUR WORK WILL WORK.
GOLD COMMITTEE SCHOOLS PROGRAM
IS TO ACHIEVE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. WE DO THIS BY VIEWING
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AS AN EQUITY
ENHANCING STRATEGY BELL LIVES
WITH A WIDE RANGE OF STATE
SCHOOL STATE SCHOOL AND DISTRICT
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES. YOU
SCHOOLS WILL INCORPORATE LARGE
STATE INVESTMENTS IN YOUTH
FOCUSED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
RUSSIAN UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
EXPANDED LEARN. AS WELL AS THE
ONGOING EFFORTS INVOLVING THE
MULTI TIER SYSTEM SUPPORT.
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS AND
ULTIMATELY OUR STATEWIDE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT FOR SCHOOL
IMPROVEMENT. TO DO THIS WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT SUSTAINABILITY
WILL BE WILL BE ESSENTIAL AND
WE'RE DOING THIS BY CREATING A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE. FIRST BELIEVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER WILL
ACT AS A HOBBY OF THIS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SYSTEM AND WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DESIGNING
TECHNICAL SYSTEM CONTENT
DEVELOPING THE TECHNICAL
DELIVERY MODEL. AND ORGANIZING
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS THIS RPA FOR THE WEEK
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER
WITHOUT THAT YOU WORK WILL
FINISH OUR SELECTION PROCESS
THIS WEEK SO THAT WE CAN DOUBTS
THE AWARDEE MAY EIGHTEENTH STATE
BOARD VIA. THIS WILL BE DONE IN
TIME TO BEGIN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THE FIRST ROUND OF
GRANTEES. AND EARLY FALL TWENTY
TWENTY. HE HAD REACHED TECHNIQUE
SYSTEM CENTER WILL BE TASKED
WITH PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL THE
BALLS APPROX. COACHING AND
RELATED AND RELATE SUPPORT. TO
ESTABLISH OR EXPAND COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. OUR GOAL WILL BE TO
SELECT THESE REGIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS OVER THE
SUMMER SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN TO
PUT THE SYSTEM IN PLACE IN THE
FALL. I HOPE Y. TAKE A MOMENT
JUST THE BANK RCD STOP. ARM WHAT
WE HAVE DONE SINCE THE JANUARY
BOARD MEETING. WHERE THE STATE
FRAMEWORK- BOB WAS APPROVED- IS
GET OUT HE'S BE ABLE TO GET OUT
. RFA GRAPHS WE POSTED THE- THE-
REQUEST FOR APPLICATIONS FOR THE
PLANNING GRANTS- IN IN EARLY
FEBRUARY- WE HAVE HAD. OVER. TWO
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED ONE TO BE
EXACT- FOR PLANNING GRANTS WE'RE
CONCLUDING THE CALIBRATION OF
THE SCORING THIS WEEK THAT'S
PLAN GRANTS WILL BE ANNOUNCED AT
THE MAY EIGHTEENTH- STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION MEETING. I'M ALSO
REALLY PLEASED TO TELL YOU. THAT
WE HAD OVER EIGHTY SEVEN WE HAD
EIGHTY SEVEN APPLICATIONS. FOR
IMPLEMENTATION GRAPHS. THAT
INCLUDES OVER. SEVEN HUNDRED.
SEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOL SUCKS THESE
APPLICATIONS ARE ALSO BEING
SUPPORTED CALIBRATED. I'M WILL
BE ANNOUNCED- AT THE AWARDS WILL
BE ANNOUNCED AT THE- AT THE
BOARD MEETING IN MAC. AND AS YOU
KNOW. MANY SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
THE COMMUTE SCHOOLS PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM IS AN EQUITY DRIVEN
PROGRAM. B. STATUTORY PRIORITY
IS FOR OVER 80% OF THE SCHOOLS
TO HIGH PRIORITY TO HAVE 80% OR
HIGHER. OTHER STUDENT MOMENT. BE
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER CLICK HERE
. I'M PLEASED TO TELL YOU OF
THESE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOL
SEX. OVER 60% OF THE APPLICANTS
HOT OVER 80% OF THEIR STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED AS UNDUPLICATED. AS
THE STOPPER MOVES FORWARD- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
UPDATE YOU. CONTINUING TO
CAPTURE THE SPIRIT OF THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MOVEMENT. AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALWAYS
ELEVATE THE ASSETS OF OUR
STUDENTS. THEIR FAMILIES OUR
TEACHERS. THEIR SCHOOLS AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES IT'S NOT MY
HONOR TO TURN THE MIKE OVER TO
BROOKLYN WILLIAMS THE SENIOR
ADVISER TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
WILL SHARE WITH US A LITTLE BIT
OF HER EXPERIENCE ON THE GROUND
ORGANIZING IS STOPS IN COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS IN THE BAY AREA.
BROOKLYN THANK YOU SO MUCH STEVE
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY I AM
AGAIN IN THIS RECORD WILLIAMS I
AM A SENIOR ADVISER TO THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- AND IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I RECENTLY JOINED A
CD IS TO SUPPORT. I THINK
MUSICAL MOVEMENT IT'S SOMETHING
I FEEL VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
HAVE ON THE GROUND EXPERIENCE
HELPING TO BUILD OUT COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. IN OAKLAND A PARTICULAR
AND IN OAKLAND'S OLDEST
CONTINUATION SCHOOL SO IT'S
SUPPORTING A VERY VULNERABLE
POPULATION AND PEOPLE. AS OFFERS
HAND HOW BUILDING OUT THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODEL HELP TO
IMPROVE OUR SCHOOL CLASS AND
CULTURE. WHICH ULTIMATELY LED TO
INCREASE OUR GRADUATION RATES-
OUR OUR STUDENTS NEED A LOT OF
SUPPORT. AND OUR CURRENT STAFF
ARE EXTREMELY STRICT IN CIRCLE
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MODEL FOR
ME IS AN ALL HANDS ON DECK
OPPORTUNITY- AND TO BRING IN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT WE
KNOW OUR YOUNG PEOPLE NEED AND
THRIVE WHEN THEY GET THEIR NEEDS
MET- AND SO. THRILLED TO HEAR
AND NOT SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT
THERE ARE SEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS
EAGERLY ANTICIPATING THESE
FUNDS- SOME OF MY CONVERSATIONS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- FOLKS ARE
EXCITED ABOUT BRINGING IN
SERVICES SUCH AS- HOUSING
NAVIGATORS WE KNOW WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA-
FOLKS WANTING TO BRING IN- FOLKS
TO HELP SUPPORT OUR- FAMILY WHO
ARE WHO ARE HOUSING INSECURE-
SUPPORTS LIKE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
COUNSELORS. YOU KNOW EVERYONE
KNOWS AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC ARE YOUNG PEOPLE FACT-
ON IN DEALING WITH MANY MANY
CHALLENGES AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S GOALS
MOVEMENT AND ALL THE SUPPORT
THAT ITS ARTISTS. BECAUSE IT
REALLY IS LIKE I SAID AND ALL
HANDS ON DECK EFFORTS AND THE
STATE AS WELL AS ALL THE LOCAL
AGENCIES ACTING UP TO THE PLATE
AND. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR-
IT'S IMPROVED BY FOLKS THE
GROUND. AND AT EVERY LEVEL. SO
WHAT IT IS THEY THAT- OUR
STUDENTS NEED ALL THE SUPPORT
CAN GET THANK SO MUCH YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU BROUGH.
THANK YOU TO DO THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE STOCK. THIS SONG OF
TOUCH. TODAY ON WE LOOK FORWARD
. TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE. YEAH CAN RESULT
THANK YOU MORE. LOCAL THE L. A.
U. SCHOOL DIST- AND CENTER FOR
COMMITTEE SCHOOLING. SORTIR
FIRST FROM THE UCLA CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOL IN. SHARE MY
SCREEN HERE THE CASE HE SAID.
FROM HERE AND ME OKAY. COMPORT
EVERYONE NAME IS SAKSHI TO SOME
DIRECT UCLA FOR SCHOOLING REALLY
REALLY TO BE HERE- TO WITH STEVE
NELSON AS STEVE MENTIONED WE ALL
COME NOT HELLO OF WORK IN LA TO-
I HAVE A IN TEN YEARS NOW HELP
DESIGN AND DEVELOP THE UC
COMMUNITY SCHOOL. AND UNIFIED
AND TOWN THAT SERVES ABOUT I
NEED TO DO FROM CHANGE THROUGH
TWELVE. AND THOUSAND C. L. A.
RIVER THE GO OR FOR IN A IN HIGH
ED ON THE SCHOOLS. IN PREPARING
FOR HIS GEN COLLEGE. BUILDING ON
THIS SUCCESS ARE YOU SEE LIKE
PARTNERED WITH HIGH NEED L. UST
SITE FOR EXAMPLE IN SOUTH LA
BECAUSE THE ENROLLMENT IN THIS
HISTORIC NINETEEN TWENTY SIX
SCHOOL HAD DECLINED FROM ALMOST
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS TO THREE
HUNDRED. BY ADDING GRADE LEVELS
AND PARTNERSHIPS MAN IS
REESTABLISHING ITS PLACE. AT THE
CENTER OF ITS COMMUNITY. YOUR
TODAY SURE LAST RUN RESEARCH AT
THESE TWO SITES. AND OTHERS IN
HOPES OF INFORMED THE STATE'S
EFFORT. I WOULD SET UP WANTED IN
OF FOR THE VISION SO FORTH IN
THE STATE'S. THANK SCHOOLS ARE
NOW APPROACH THAT HE'S TRANSFER
APPROACH. ROOTED IN. ARE YOU A
CENTER ON COMMUNITY SCHOOLING
NOT SCHOOLS TO MAKE THE VERY
HIGH STAKES. DECADE OF RESEARCH
ON SCHOOL CHANGE A TIRE US THAT
YOU. ARE TO CAUGHT IN REFORM
BILL. BUT INJURING ID AND CAN
HELP US THINK AND ACT
DIFFERENTLY. SO I WANT TO SHARE
THREE STORIES TODAY THAT
ILLUSTRATE THESE IDEAS AND WHAT
IT WILL TAKE. ABOUT THE SAME.
STATES EFFORT. I FOR STORY IT'S
A SANCTUARIES. AND IT FOR ON THE
DEMOCRATS STRUCK AND- I'M THAT
AUTHENTIC PARTNERSHIP AND REFORM
INTO. MEET ITS BALANCE IMMIGRANT
RIGHT ORGANIZER RIGHT THE TAPE.
WHEN THE USE OKAY DISCLOSED. AND
THEY CAN. TO HELP GUIDE THE IN
THE- NOW IT PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
CAN'T. IMMIGRANT FAMILY LEAVE
CLINIC. SHE WITH STUDENTS
TEACHERS LAWYERS ARTISTS.
FAMILIES THAT ARE THE SCHOOL
INSTEAD A VERY ROBUST BY DEATH.
AS THE CENTURY SCHOOL SUPPORTED
BY NOT JUST SPEAKING. BUT
PRACTICING AS MOVE. MULTI
LANGUAGE. RISK AND AFTER ARTS
PROGRAMS AT THE TOP OF ABOUT THE
DEMOCRAT. IT'S PERFECT SCHOOL
CULTURE AND IT TOOK YEARS I'VE-
DEMOCRATS ENGAGEMENT THE AND IT
WILL DEMAND SAME TO SUSTAIN IT.
THE LESSON HERE A LOOK AT LEVEL
OF OUR SYSTEM THE VALUES
IMPRINTS OF DEMOCRATIC
ENGAGEMENT DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND
INTERESTS COMING TO THE TABLE TO
DELIBERATE AND MAKE DECISIONS
AND SOLVE PROBLEMS TOGETHER.
SECOND STORY IS ABOUT THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER DATA. AND
THIS IS I'M SITTING HERE IN THE
LIBRARY AT THE SCHOOL WITH OUR
PRINCIPAL LADY GARCIA. YEAH THE
END OF MANY MANY MEETINGS WHEN
WE OPENED IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
FEATURES ARE CLICKING READING
DATA WHICH IS VISUALIZED IN THE
SLOT HERE. IN SPANISH AND
ENGLISH AND THAT WAS THE TIME
WHEN PARENTS WERE REQUIRED TO
SIGN WAIVERS TO ENROLL IN OUR
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM.
FEATURES A CAPITATED GOING- AT
TWELVE THIRTEEN YEARS NOW
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE ITS
VALUES. THEY TEACH STUDENTS TO
USE THEIR OWN DATA TO SET GOALS
AND IMPROVE WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THEIR PARENTS AND AS A RESULT OF
THE SCHOOLS DECADELONG
COMMITMENT TO COLLECTING AND
USING ITS OWN DATA. THE UCLA
COMMUNITY SCHOOL GRADUATED 52%
OF ITS SENIORS LAST YEAR WITH
THE. STATE SEAL OF BI LITERACY.
SO THE TAKE AWAY HERE
CHRISTENSEN. COMMUNITY BASED
DATA. THAT CAPTURES THE
COMPLEXITY IS TO DEVELOPMENT.
LEARNING WEALTHY. AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL USE DATA AS WELL AS
STORYTELLING TO INFORM
IMPLEMENTATION AND CELEBRATE
PROGRESS. MY LAST STORIES ABOUT
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL WORK FIRST
AND IMPORTANCE OF DEVELOPING
FULL CHILD WILL TEACHER
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THAT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO DO HER BEST WORK AND
SUPPORT THEM TO STAY. IT'S
DIFFICULT ON THIS TEACHER
APPRECIATION DAY TRANSACTION OF
MORE PRESSING CONCERN AT THE
STATE LEVEL IN TEACHER
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION. THE
PANDEMIC WITH XCELERATED
RETIREMENTS IN TEACHERS ARE
EXPERIENCING UNPRECEDENTED
STRESS STRESS THAT ALSO EXTENDS
ACROSS THE FULL COMPLEMENT EACH
BE PEACEFUL PROFESSIONALS
REPORTERS NURSES LIBRARIANS
SOCIAL WORKERS PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
MARK. UCLA COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ARE
STAFFED BY HIGHLY QUALIFIED AND
DIVERSE PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE
STAYING AT HIGHER THAN AVERAGE
RATES. IN PART BECAUSE. IT'S
GONNA BE OVER THEIR WORK. YOU
SEE I MEAN YOU GOT ONE OF FOUR.
L. UNIFIED KILEY SCHOOLS AND THE
GREEN THAT THAT WAS THE STATE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. WITH THE
DISTRICT UNION AND COMMUNITY
THAT'S A LOCAL AND EXTRA. FOR
HOW MECHANIC. HI ARE ONE OF
THREE. THIS MODEL SUPPORT BY
ELLIE U. S. T. AND BOTH YOU SEE
UP MANY SCHOOLS BEEN USED AS A
TIME. TO HIGH AND WORK TEACHERS
. LIKE JOANNE. ADDED PICTURES.
HERE TEACHER OF COLOR APPROACHED
PARTNERS AND YOU DEVELOP BASED
CURRICULUM IS. THANK LOCAL YET
SYSTEM LEVEL IS PROFOUND SHE-
BUT POLICY CENTER THE L. A.
PILOTS A GREEN. ARE GOOD X. OF
LARGE. TAKING TO TRY EACH. TO
DEVELOP. CONCEPT OF TO EDUCATION
. YOUR SET WHICH IS OUR AT THE
SEE LIKE SCHOOL TO RIGHT HERE IS
A POWERFUL MAN. I SEE YOU I AM
WE ARE ONE AND IT'S THIS WRECK
AND SENSE OF COLLECTIVE AGENCY
THAT DRIVE SOCIAL CHANGE AND IT
BOUNCES EQUITY KEEPING THE
TRANSFORMATIVE PROMISE OF
COMMUNITY SCHOOLING FRANKEN
CENTER WILL REQUIRE US ALL TO
APPROACH OUR WORK DIFFERENTLY IN
COMMUNITY RATHER THAN SIDELOAD
BY PROGRAMS AND REFORMS. BUT
THAT'S- YOUR DAD LIKE TO END
WITH A QUOTE FOR WHATEVER
TEACHERS. THE MOST JOY IN
COMMUNITIES AND STUFF THE REALLY
. THAT WE BUILT OVER THE THESE
AND STUDENTS. RECOGNIZE THAT
WHAT DID YOU OUR CLASS IS ONLY
ONE FOR OF TRANSFER IMMERSES.
THEIR TEACHERS THAT ARE KEY TO
ALL DIFFERENT KINDS OF REALLY
AMAZING WORK IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THINKING ABOUT HOW WE LIFT
EACH OTHER. AND FIND WAYS TO
CRIED TOGETHER ADVOCATES FOR THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED AT THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
OKAY FINAL SPEAKER PLEASE THE LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ALLISON YOSHIMOTO TERRY THE
CHIEF ACADEMIC OFFICER FOR THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. ANGELES HAS BEEN
COLLABORATING NATIONALLY IN THE
INVESTMENT AND DELIVERY OF
COMMUNITY SCHOOL COLORS AND
SUPPORTS. ALONG WITH OUR
PARTNERS THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TODAY TO SHARE
PERSPECTIVES ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. AND THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO BETTER SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES SERVED
THROUGH THE CREATION AND
EXPANSION OF COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
THIS TWO POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IS INVESTING
IN OUR FUTURE. AS MR ZIMMER DR
HUNDRED OTHERS SPEAKERS TO SHARE
TODAY THE WORK HAS BEEN ONGOING
- IN ADDITION TO UCLA BEING A
LEAD AGENCY THAT WRAPS SUPPORT
AROUND AND WITHIN OUR SCHOOLS WE
ALSO HAVE. COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS AND IN
ADDITION THE DISTRICT L. UNIFIED
HAS UPLIFTED OUR OWN. PROGRAM
AND PRESENTLY THIRTY FOUR
COMMUNITY SCHOOL SUPPORTED BY
THE DISTRICT HAVE ALSO BEEN
DESIGNATED. RIGHT NOW I'M
SCHOOLS IN COLLABORATION WITH
MANY SCHOOL STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING ADMINISTRATORS
TEACHERS COACHES COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND NATIONALLY BY
NATIONAL AND LABOUR PARTNERS. AT
LAST AS UNIFIED WILL FORWARD. TO
DEVELOP A PLAN NEXT. THERE'S
PRIORITY THAT SERVICE ONE IS
THAT EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AS A
PRIORITY AREA. AT IN ADDITION
IT'S WEEKS AS WE FOCUS ON
EXPANDED LEARNING TIME AND THE
OTHER THREE PILLARS I WE ALSO
WANT TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE FIRST
TEACHING AND LEARNING FOR EVERY
CHILD. AND THE INCORPORATION AND
BREEDING OF OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES SUCH AS PROJECT BASED
LEARNING LINKS LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
HAVE REAL WORLD WELL PURPOSE
THEY'RE LEARNING HAVE RELATIVELY
MANY DEVELOP TO THEM.
ADMINISTRATIVE IS ANOTHER AREA
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO FIND
COLLABORATION DISTRIBUTED
LEADERSHIP AND CREATING A
POSITIVE SCHOOL CULTURE IS THE
SPECIFICS SET THAT ARE
ADMINISTRATORS NEED SUPPORT WITH
CAPACITY BUILDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE COOK ING SUPPORTS OUR
TOP PRIORITY. ADMINISTRATORS AS
YOU KNOW DO EVERYTHING RELATED
TO PERSONNEL INSTRUCTION
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
COMPLIANCE THE LEAD WITH
POSITIVE BEHAVIOR SUPPORT AND
OVERSEEING ALL OPERATIONAL
ISSUES AND IT'S IMPORTANT AT
THIS TIME THAT WE COLLABORATE.
WITH OUR ADMINISTRATORS TO
RETHINK THEIR ROLE OF
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THAT
COCHING SUPPORT IS A TOP
PRIORITY. ALSO AS WE WORK WITH
OUR FEDERAL. OUT WE- REALLY
ALONG WITH OTHER DISTRICTS HAVE
TO FIND A WAY TO HAVE THIS
PERSISTENT SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE AND THAT'S REALLY TOP OF
MIND FOR US BECAUSE THIS WORK
TAKES TIME. TO DO WELL. NUMBER
ONE OF ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
THINK ABOUT OFFICIALLY BREEDING
FUNDING AND LEVERAGING FUNDS SET
ASIDE FOR EXAMPLE FOR MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT MANAGED CARE OR
OTHER FEDERAL STATE LOCAL
FUNDING STREAMS IN A TARGETED
WAY WOULD BE OF SUPPORT TO S.
FOR EXAMPLE OUR DIVISION OF
STUDENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED
TO MAXIMIZE YOUR REIMBURSEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES CIVIL CLOSER TO
BECOMING A DISTRICT OPERATED
SELF SUSTAINING HUMANS HUMAN
SERVICE ENTITY BY LEVERAGING
COMMUNITY START COMMUNITY SCHOOL
FUNDING. OUR MENTAL SCHOOL OUR
SCHOOL WITH HEALTH SERVICES. I
IN CONSTANT IN COLLABORATION
WITH UNLESS COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH. CAN ALSO
DELIVERED STRONG SERVICES TO OUR
FAMILIES TO REALLY COMBAT THE
HOUSING AND SECURITY IS THE JOB
OF SECURITIES IN THE FOOD
INSECURITIES THAT OUR FAMILY
CENTER AT OFTEN ARE BARRIERS TO
STUDENTS SUCCEEDING ACADEMICALLY
. SO COMMITTEE SCHOOL FUNDING
ALLOWS OR THIS REINVESTMENT. IT
PREVENTATIVE CARE EARLY
INTERVENTION CARE AND INTENSIVE
SERVICES AS WELL. I IN ADDITION
TO THIS IDEA OF READING FUNDING
- WE ALSO WANT TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE BRAID SUPPORTS FOR THE
COUNTY THE STATE THE STATE THE
COUNTY DISTRICT LEVELS IN
REGARDS TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NEEDED AND ALSO
ACADEMIC SUPPORTS NEED FOR
TUTORING AND ADDITIONAL MULTI
TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORTS. AND
IF WE FIND STATE COUNTY AT
DISTRICTS SEPARATELY- OUR
STUDENTS ARE IN SCHOOL SO IT BE
IT HELPFUL TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
AGAIN PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCENTIVES TO BRAID FUNDING AND
SUPPORTS THEY HAVE A REALLY
TRULY REPREHENSIBLE SERVICE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODEL UP WHERE
THE STUDENTS SAID EVERY DAY IN
OUR SCHOOLS. AND LASTLY. THIS
WILL TAKE LOCALLY DRIVEN WORK TO
REIMAGINE THE USE OF ALL CAPS
FINDS OUT THESE COULD BE
STRUCTURED AROUND THE FOUR
PILLARS- THAT ARE CALLED OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL FRAMEWORK.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO LEVERAGING
THESE DOLLARS TO PRIORITIZE
PREVENTION RATHER THAN
INTERVENTION- TO WORK FROM TO
WORK TO BECOME FAMILY
SUPPORTERS. RATHER THAN
REPORTERS AND TO REALLY ADDRESS
BABY TO ADULT SERVICES AND THE
WORK THAT WE DO. SO WETHANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND LEADERSHIP
UNTIL THE SPEAKERS THAT WERE
HERE TODAY AT THE INCREASED FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOL IN SUPPORT OF
THE MILLIONS OF CHILDREN ACROSS
CALIFORNIA B. PLEASE ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU A LOT TO CHEW ON THERE. AND
I KNOW- MEMBERS HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS ON THIS COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS PROPOSAL BUT I KNOW WE
HAVE. FIRST TIME WE HAVE BOTH
TURN A LITTLE BIT SO LET'S JUST
. OUR QUORUM FIRST. MCCARTY HERE
. CHOI YEAH LEE. MEDINA BUT
DONALD HERE REYES HERE WALDRON
FONG HERE. OKAY WE'LL START WITH
THE QUESTIONS ON THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ISSUE MR DOLLAR. THANK
YOU A MISTER CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE
THE- THE PRESENT AND- I DON'T
THINK UNIFIED TOO MANY PEOPLE
AGAINST COMMUNITY SCHOOLS I THE
FACT THAT WE NEED THEM. OPERANDS
OF MODEL AND DOING IT AT THE
SCHOOL SUCH AS A GOOD ONE THING
I WOULD QUESTION THOSE THE USE
OF PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MONEY FOR ALL OF THE EFFORTS
SOME OF THE EFFORTS LIKELY
COMPORT WITH PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT IN ITS MISSION SOME OF THE
EFFORTS LIKELY DO NOT COMPORT
WITH PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT SO
I QUESTION A SOME OF THE USE OF
THE MONEY- GOING TO COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS NOT THAT I OPPOSE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS BUT- THAT I
WANNA MAKE SURE THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT IS AIMED AT THE
CORE MISSION OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHICH IS TO EDUCATE. IN THE
CLASSROOM. BUT WITH THAT I DO
HAVE A QUESTION IT'S UNLIKELY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE. THE COORDINATION
GRANTS THAT SUPPORT THIS. OF
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THAT IS. THE
ONGOING NESS IF YOU WILL OF CAN
SCHOOLS WE WHY WOULD. WHY WOULD
WE- WANT TO US- ELIMINATE THE-
THE COORDINATION GRANTS MAYBE
SOMEONE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COULD COMMENT ON THAT
THANK YOU. ALL FINISHED TANK THE
PARTMINER FINANCE. DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSED TOTALLY THE CORONATION
GRANTS BETWEEN. IT AS PART OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD AT
COORDINATION OF COMPONENTS AND-
INCLUDE. MAKING SURE THAT A
FIFTY PLAN FOR THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AND ALSO COORDINATING
WITH OTHER OUTSIDE AGENCIES AND
PARTNERS TO ENSURE LONG TERM
PROGRAMMING AND SO WE THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS WORK
AND SCHOOLS ARE STARTING THIS
WORK IN GETTING THIS WORK FROM
DAY ONE. WHICH IS WHY WE'VE
INCORPORATED AS PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD AND
SPELLED IT OUT IN TRAILER BILL
THE DIFFERENT COMPONENTS OF
CREATING A SUSTAINABILITY
PLANNING AND COORDINATING
SERVICES AS PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS. I THINK I
GOT MOST OF THAT. SO IT'S GONNA
PART OF THE IMPLEMENTATION. WALK
WE DO SO TO THEN WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN TO HOW DOES THAT. HOW DOES
THAT END UP BEING. HELPING THIS
. OF THE PROGRAM. SURE THAT. THE
COORDINATION COME- AND- AT
SECURING LONG TERM FUNDING
STREAMS AND COMMITMENTS AND
COORDINATING WITH COMPUTER
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO SUPPORT
ONGOING PROGRAMMING. AND SO
WE'VE INCORPORATED THAT AS PART
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD. BY
INCLUDING AND- THOSE COME. AT OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION GRANT AND WE
- INCORPORATED THE FUNDING THAT
WAS FOR THE COORDINATION. GRANT
INTO THE IMPLEMENTATION GRANT.
GREAT THANK YOU I THINK ONE WAY
WE CAN ADDRESSES THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ADDRESSES. IS LONG THE
MONEY IS BEING USED FOR A LOT
NINETY EIGHT PURPOSES WE CAN
INCREASE THE BASE GRANT. AND
THEN COULD HAVE A LEEWAY. IF
SEARCH. TO GO TO SCHOOL MODEL AT
SOME SCHOOLS LATEST WERE ALL. IT
MAY BE. OF WITHOUT FRIEND
SCHOOLS OUT OF THE GATE. RIGHT
IN THE BASE ALLOCATION. THERE'LL
BE MORE MONEY. FOR DISTRICTS TO
USE. TO PUT FORWARD. AT TO MOVE
FORWARD IN EFFORTS LIKE THIS NOT
ALWAYS OUT AND- PARTNERSHIPS ARE
IMPORTANT BUDGET WE'RE DOING
THIS ON A VOLUNTEER BASIS. IT'S
GOING TO COLLAPSE NOT
SUSTAINABLE- MORE WERE ALWAYS
GOING OUT AND SEEKING CORPORATE
HELP OR SOME TYPE OF. THIRD
PARTY TO HELP US OUT- THAT'S-
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THAT'S ONE
THINGS BECOME TENUOUS AND NOT
SUSTAINABLE QUITE FRANKLY FOR MY
POINT. AS ONE PERSON LEAVES THAT
PERSON KIND OF AS THE LYNCH. AND
THEN THIS MODEL COLLAPSES AT A
SCHOOL OR DISTRICT. SO AGAIN
NOTHING FOR YOU TO RESPOND TO
TODAY ON THAT FRONT BUT JUST
THAT IF WE DO- SIGNIFICANTLY
FUND SCHOOLS BETTER. WE CAN
SUPPORT EFFORTS LIKE THIS WHERE
APPROPRIATE WITH NINETY EIGHT
MONEY THANK YOU. DR CHOI IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRANCE. THE
DOCTOR AND THEN SOMEONE FOR
DOCTOR FONG. LIKE THE LIKE THAT
THAT'S OKAY DR CHOI THANK YOU
IT'S HOW TO SCHOOL RISK PUBLICLY
TO SCORES- WITH A BE ELIGIBLE
FOR HIS OF FRIENDS. YES THEY
WILL BE. OKAY GOOD TO HEAR THANK
YOU THIS. YES OKAY SO MEMORY S.
WELL IN LIGHT OF THIS HISTORIC
INVESTMENT IN OUR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS I THINK IT IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAREFULLY
CONSIDER HOW THE STEPS IT'S
GOING TO BE DESIGNED AND
IMPLEMENTED SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
BEST USE OF THE DOLLARS AND I DO
WANT TO. CHAU MY APPRECIATION TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. AND FOR THE CLOSE
ATTENTION TO IMPROVE THE CURRENT
STATUTE. I THINK THE CHANGES
WILL HELP TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. THE PLAN FOR COMMUTER
SCHOOLS. STRONGER BUT ONE OF THE
BIG WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S BASED ON BEST PRACTICES AND
RESEARCH. I DO HAVE A QUESTION-
WHAT TECHNICAL IS IT ASSISTANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE SCV DEVELOPED FOR
SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION OF
SUSTAINABILITY AT THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS MODEL. FOR CD. YES THANK
YOU- LET ME GET MY VIDEO OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND WE AGREE WITH YOU
THAT- THAT THIS TECHNIQUE BOTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE
ABSOLUTELY IS ESSENTIAL TO
SUSTAIN THIS PROGRAM TO
ESTABLISHING BEST PRACTICES ARE
. ACTUALLY AS AS AS AS- I'LL
SEND YOU SOME OF THE TOWER TALK
TO REALLY AREN'T SUPPORTING
SCHOOLS ON THE GROUND WITH THESE
TRANSFORMATIONAL. ARE BUT ME
DISCUSS- OUR OUR PLAN- IN THAT
DIDN'T THAT HAPPY TO CHANCE ANY
ANY FOLLOW UP WE HAVE RIGHT NOW-
THIS WEEK WE ARE WE ARE SCORING
THE APPLICATIONS FOR WHAT ARE
CALLED WE'RE GOING TO BE CALLED
BELIEVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTER- FOR THE STATE- TO DESIGN
THE COMPREHENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN
COOPERATION- WITH- CP- WITH THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION ARE CAN
COORDINATION WITH OR I SHOULD
SAY IT YOU'RE KIND. OF JUST A
COLLECTION CHIP WITH THE-
EXISTING THAT ARE GOING ON
AROUND MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT. THE BOB BOB WILL
ESTABLISH BEST PRACTICES DOES.
THE ARE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
ARE AND I WON STATE. THANK THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX. WE ARE GOING TO
ASKING SCHOOL. TO TRANSFORM
RELATIONSHIPS- AT SCHOOL SITES
TO HAVE VERY DIFFERENT TYPES OF
. ROLE ACTIVE ARE PART- TO- AS
WAS REFERENCE BOOK PORT TO STAY
AND SUSTAINABLE- AND SO IT WILL
BE A COMPLEX NTEGRATED- AND WE
CAN COMPREHENSIVE- TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE MODEL. FROM THIS HUB
WE ARE THEN GOING TO- WE ARE
THEN GOING TO- HAVE AN RFA- IN
THE COMING MONTHS FOR REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS-
THAT WILL- IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
WITH THREE BILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM WE'RE LOOKING STATEWIDE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT- BE ISSUES ON
THE GROUND EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW
THERE ARE THERE ARE
COMMONALITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE KNOW THAT THE IMPACTS
OF CO GOOD- PRE EXISTING
PERSISTENT DISPARITIES BUT ALSO
IMPACTED FIRES. WE HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS THROUGHOUT THIS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND SO OUR
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS WILL BE THE PRODUCT
ROUTE WELL ON IMPLEMENTING
COACHING WORKING IN PARTNERSHIPS
WITH ALI AS AND EVEN INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL SITES- TO MAKE THIS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. RIDLEY
THIS PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
TRANSFORMATION JOURNEY REAL ARE
ON THE GROUND I LOOK FORWARD TO
COMING BACK. ONCE WE HAVE. HELLO
TECHNICAL SO CENTER IDENTIFIED
ONCE HOW ARE REGIONAL TECHNICAL
SYSTEM CENTERS IN PLACE OCTOBER
BACK OUR PROGRESS IN ENGAGE IN
DIALOGUE WITH YOU- WITH WITH
HOCKEY CONTEST FOR THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU ONE OF
THE ONE IN IN YOUR- WHEN YOU
JUST ABOUT THE THAT WOULD BE A
COMP INTEGRATED DON'T MAKE IT TO
. PLEASE I YOU YEAH ARE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OKAY I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS BILL WRAP IT OUT FIRST
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. BUT
THAT WAS CHAIR I WANTED TO BUILD
ON SOME OF THE QUESTIONS ASKED
BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH
OF HONEST ON SUSTAINABILITY- IN
TERMS OF THE PROGRAM SO FAR AND
- DO YOU L. WHAT ARE STUDENT OUT
COME TO IS. WHAT IS THE DATA ON
THE STUDENT OUT. ON THE COMES
RIGHT NOW- I WE SEEN. IMPROVE I
MEAN WHAT'S WHAT DOES THE
NUMBERS LOOK LIKE. MAYBE THAT'S
RECEIVE I CAN AYE YEAH I CAN
TAKE THE EFFECT I CAN TAKE TAKE
THIS SO AS A THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. AS AS I NOTED IN IN
THE INITIAL- IN MY INITIAL
REMARKS WE ARE WORKING WITH WEST
HAD. TO TO GATHER THE STUDENT
OUTCOME DATA. FROM THE- TWENTY
PARTNER L. EA. THAT IS DATA THAT
WE ARE WE ARE WORKING WITH RIGHT
NOW- I'M HAPPY TO REPORT BACK
YOU ON OTHER COMPREHENSIVE-
LEARNING. HOW WE ARE ALSO- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH WEST SPENDING
TIME ON THE GROUND- WITH. THESE
WITH THE SCHOOLS IN THE PILOT
PROGRAM. TO GET FEEDBACK ON ON
BEST PRACTICES ARE
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES. HI AS
I SAID THIS IS A PROCESS THAT'S
ONGOING RIGHT NOW- I THINK. IN
IN THE FALL WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
COME BACK. WITH A LESSONS
LEARNED BUT ALSO A COMPREHENSIVE
PICTURE OF OUTCOME DATA THAT WE
COULD SHARE WITH YOU FROM FROM
THE INITIAL WHILE PROGRAM. IS SO
LET ME THAN THIS WHAT YOU
MEASURING RIGHT NOW WE WENT AS
YOU TALK TO WITH- WITH WEST
ADMIN. WHAT ARE THE FACTORS WHAT
ARE YOU ASKING. WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING AT. SO IF I THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE CALL QUESTION
SO WE'RE AT- AT- IT'S TO NOW
COME. IN TERMS OF- IN TERMS OF
THE TENDER- IN INTER OF GRADES
IN TURN. OF BEHAVIORAL FOR- I IN
TURN AND ALSO- AND ALSO LOOKING
AT PARENT AND COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION- THOSE ARE OF
COURSE WE ARE HOT DASH.
INDICATORS FOR THAT BUT WEST
THAT HAS DESIGNED I'M SURVEY
INSTRUMENTS TO BE ABLE TO.
ASCERTAIN YOU KNOW HOW THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE PLAYING OUT ON
THE GROUND AND WE HOPE TO LOOK
AT THAT. HI IN A COMBINATION
WITH THE STUDENT OUTCOME DATA.
DOT DOT ALSO WILL BE COMBINED
WITH SOME OF THIS MORE OFTEN IF
YOU WILL- KIND OF INTERVIEW
BASED DATA- I MORE UP TO DATE-
ARE MORE. I WANT STATE AND GO
BUT I. BUT BUT CERTAINLY KIND
PUBLIC LISTENING SESSION TYPE
OF. LEARNING THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THE THESE PILOT
SCHOOLS AS WELL SO THOSE ARE THE
THREE AREAS- THAT THAT OUGHT
THAT WE LOOKED STATE STREET
OUTCOME DATA- YOU KNOW BEING
ABLE TO KIND OF. MEASURE B. B.
THE PARTNERSHIP AND ENGAGEMENT.
BOB AND ALSO LEARNING AND
LISTENING FROM FROM THE PILOT
SCHOOLS ARE ON. THE GROUND. I
HOPE THAT HELPS CLEAR NO THAT
DOES ARE YOU BY YOU SEE THAT-
SMALLER SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
BIGGER CHALLENGES THAN ONE ARE
WHAT ARE THE G. THAT ARE BEING
FACED RIGHT NOW I I'M JUST.
TRYING TO WRAP MY HANDS AROUND.
HOW WE EVALUATE WHETHER THIS
PROGRAM IS SUCCESSFUL IN
ACHIEVING THE GOALS AND HOW TO
FINE TUNE IT. YEAH ABSOLUTELY
I'LL GIVEN THE- ANSWER BY I
WOULD ALSO AND I KNOW OUT SINCE
IT'S TURNED ON HERKIMER L. U. IS
ONE OF OUR- JUST. SO I DO YOU
WOULD IT YET SHE COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT TO. THE CHILD THERE'S
NOW. ARE IN THIS PROCESS. BUT I
SAY THINK YOU YOU GIVE US A PLUS
WE BEEN VERY INTENTIONAL. ABOUT
THIS BEING. A ABOUT OUR COURSE
SMALL AND RURAL DISTRICTS BEING
FULL PARTICIPANTS IN IN IN THIS
PROGRAM SO MUCH SO THAT THE S.
B. THAT THE STATE COURT-
INSTRUCTED US WELL IN
COOPERATION TO OPT OUT- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE GIVING
PREFERENCE TO WORLD DISTRICTS.
IN. THIS TIME. IN TERMS OF THE
CHILD THAT WE'RE SEEING- THINK
WE ARE ALL. OF THAT THE IMPACT
OF THE PEN- A SPECIAL ONS. WHO
WERE ALREADY EXPERIENCING
VULNERABILITIES- HAS BEEN
PROFOUND. AND THAT THE
CHALLENGES OF RECONNECTING
STUDENTS ARE FAMILIES JUST. ARE
TO ADDRESSING LEARNING LOS- BUT
ALSO TO BEING ABLE TO HOP
INTEGRATED SERVICE THAT ADDRESS
TRAUMA IN GRIEF BOB BROWN ARE
AMONG THE THINGS THAT WERE
HEARING FROM OUR- THIS. COOPER
PARTNERS- ARE PART OF THE PILOT
RULES THE OF THE PILE. THE SPACE
. CHALLENGES BUT BE DIFFERENT ON
THE GROUND THEMES ARE ARE
CERTAINLY CONTRA AMONG YOUR PALS
MICHAEL WHILE WAY AND THAT'S THE. AS A DISTRICT PARTICIPATE POP
. SHOULD SHOULD BE HAPPY TO JUST
BILL BUT YOU HOW YOU THE STAGE-
AS AND I THINK. WAY YOU FRAME IT
WITHOUT THEM THE PARTNERSHIP DAY
AND LIST AND LEARNING TO ON THE
GROUND IS REALLY AND I JUST
WANTED TO ASSEMBLY FOX GIVE A
BIT OF CUT FROM THE FROM A THIS
LEVEL- WE DID IN IRAQ BUT-
THAT'S THAT'S MY- THAT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES IMITATION WHICH OF
COURSE WAS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
OF OUR TRADITIONAL DATA SOURCES
DURING THAT TIME- SO IT WAS MORE
THE QUALITATIVE SIDE. WITHOUT
THE ATTENDANCE HAD IMPROVED
ENGAGEMENT WAS MORE APPARENTAND
HIGHER AND OPINIONS WERE THAT
THE SCHOOLS WERE MORE RESPONSIVE
AND INTEGRATED SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES LIKE MENTAL MEDICAL
HEALTH WERE MORE AVAILABLE AT AT
OUR. COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. WE'RE
RIGHT ENGAGE. IN A MY- AND THAT
MAKES METHODS. RESEARCH IS
GETTING OFF THE GROUND WHERE WE
WILL LOOK AT TRADITIONAL OUTCOME
DATA LIKE IT'S SMARTER BALANCE
ATTENDANCE WE CLASSIFICATION.
REPEATED APRIL FOR INSIST. SO WE
WILL BE ABLE TO CROSS REFERENCE
TRADITIONAL STUDENT OUTCOME DATA
WITH THAT. THAT PLACE IS FROM
THE FIELD AND INNOCENT VOICES
FAMILY VOICES. EMPLOYEE VOICES.
AS WELL AS AN INDEPENDENT IF WE
WERE ABLE TO MAP OUR
PARTNERSHIPS A SPECIFICALLY FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
REGION WHICH SCHOOLS WERE
WORKING WITH WHICH PARTNERS AND
PUT THOSE ON A MAP. SO WE COULD
SEE REALLY BY LOOKING AT THE
INTERACTIVE MAP WHICH SCHOOLS
PARTNERS AND WHICH SCHOOLS
DIDN'T. AND WE'RE CURRENTLY ON
THAT AS WELL WITH ALL OF OUR-
SERVICES SO WE HAVE TO HAVE
WASTED TO. ACCESS THAT
INFORMATION SO WE COULD SEE
WHERE THE- ARE AND POOL
RESOURCES AREAS THAT THEM THE
MOST SO THAT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF A PERSPECTIVE. FROM THE
DISTRICTS THAT UP I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT IT. IN JUST MY
LAST QUESTION. I KNOW THAT FROM
SEE YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE'S A
DASHBOARD DATA SO WILL. WILL ALL
THE DATA BEEP. BE PUBLICLY
FACING WILL WE BE ABLE TO LOOK
AT THAT DATA. AT SOME POINT.
LAWYERS SURVEY YEAH. YEAH YES
AND THE BOTH THE ANSWER THANK
YOU CAN SOME CONCRETE BY- B. THE
ANSWER JORDAN IS YES TO BOTH BE
PUBLIC FACING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD BE BY BOXES WE CAN BOB
TOGETHER WITH WHAT'S THAT
PRESENT ALL OF THE DATA ALL OF
OUR TO COULD. GREAT AND THEY
THEN- AND THEN THE TIME SINCE
WHAT'S- THE WHAT'S THE- HI. I
THINK I THINK WOULD BE- ONE THE
DESPERATE FROM FROM FROM YEAR-
AND- I THINK ABOUT HOW TO GO
BACK AND CHECK AND CONFIRM THIS
BUT I THINK THAT THERE ARE THE
OTHER STUFF TO THE WHICH OUT
WHICH ALSO OUT OUT WE SHOULD BE
RIGHT THIS SUMMER AND SO WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME BACK IN
IN AND GIVE THAT TO THIS
COMMITTEE IF INVITED- THIS THIS
FALL. A VERY MUCH WE SHOULD.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU I HAVE
A AND- NUMBER OF. FIVE QUESTIONS
HERE THE IMAGE READY ASKED SO I
IN CONCERT THERE IS AGREEMENT ON
THE NOTION THAT COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE REALIZE THAT
SO MUCH OF SUCCESS OF KIDS IS
NOT ALWAYS BETWEEN YOU KNOW NINE
THREE OR WHATEVER HOURS THAT THE
TEACHERS THERE'S SO MUCH ELSE
HAPPENING. WITH BEHAVIORAL
MENTAL HEALTH- YEAH REGULAR HOW
SOCIAL IN THE COMMUNITY POP
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE TEACHERS
ARE ALWAYS THE- SAVIOR. THE
FOCUSING ON KIDS SUCCESS SO THE
NOTION HERE BRINGING RESOURCES-
IS CERTAINLY- A GOOD ONE. SO THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE IS-
TENSELY I WHO GETS IT- HOW THEY
GONNA GET IT AND HOW DO WE-
SUSTAIN ITSELF I GUESS THE FIRST
QUESTION IS FOR FINANCING I
GUESS WAS ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
SCHOOLS CALIFORNIA. IS KINDA
LOOKED RIGHT HERE ROUGHLY
SOMEWHERE CONTINUATION- MAJORITY
OR ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS OF COURSE
. AND THE PRIORITY HERE IS HIGH
POVERTY SO WHAT'S YOUR ESTIMATE
AS FAR AS HOW MANY SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE. A
COMMUNITY SCHOOL- THAT TO THEM.
PAHLAVAS TEN WITH PERMANENT
BINANCE I HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF
ME BUT I'M HAPPY TO- BUT YOUR
ESTIMATE. THANK HALF OF OUR
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA. IF YOU
LIKE IS THIS GOING TO BE THAT
THIS IS THIS THIS COMMUNITY
SCHOOL CONCEPT IS GOING TO BE A
RARE THING OF JUST A FEW THAT
YOU KNOW. LESS THAN HALF OF OUR
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA GET
THERE'S GONNA BE NO SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW MOST CALIFORNIANS
WILL SEE IN OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS.
LIVING WITH THAT OF FINANCE SO
THIS THIS PROGRAM IS OPTIONAL SO
NO SCHOOLS HAVE TO APPLY- I
DON'T I'M NOT SURE IF WE CAN
STATE THAT ALL SCHOOLS WILL
APPLY TO BECOME A COMMUNITY
SCHOOL. YEAH IN YOUR GAS IN TWO
YEARS FROM NOW HOW MANY OF OUR
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE.
COMMUNITY SCHOOL RESOURCES TO
HELP BECOME A COMMUNITY SCHOOL.
I THINK IT'S BASED ON WHO
APPLIES WE ARE IN YOUR WATER AND
WE WERE SEEING. A MESSAGE
THERE'S A ROOM. AND EIGHT
HUNDRED SCHOOL EIGHTY FOUR OR SO
APPLICATIONS REPRESENTING AROUND
SEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS HAVE
APPLIED- YOU KNOW I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE TO OFF ON AT THIS
POINT- SO IF YOU SEE SO THAT'S
LET LESS THAN TEN PERCENT. OF
THE SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS OR
SEVEN HUNDRED SO. WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT. DOUBLE THAT
TRIPLE THAT AT THE END OF THE
DAY IS THIS GOING TO BE AN
AMAZING- INVESTMENT FOR JUST HEY
YOU KNOW A SLIVER OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ARE JUST GOING TO BE.
YOU KNOW THAN THE NORMAL WE SEE
ABOUT SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND POVERTY AREAS. I
THINK AS WE MOVE THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION AS OTHER SCHOOLS
. YOU KNOW SUCCESS SUCCESSFUL
MODELS IN OUR YOUR ONE- COHORTS-
YOU KNOW MORE SCHOOLS MAY BE
INCLINED TO APPLY SO WE COULD
SEE A RAMP UP- BUT AT THIS TIME
I'M NOT SURE WE CAN YOU KNOW
ANSWER FOR SURE THAT WE KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW ALL SCHOOLS WILL
APPLY THAT ARE ELIGIBLE. BUT
WOULD YOU GUESS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS
WILL HAVE A COMMUNITY SCHOOL
RESOURCES AND WILL APPLY AND GET
MONIES OR- IN OVER 50% OF MEN.
POVERTY SCHOOLS ARE LESS. WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY. I'M NOT SURE I
CAN. HELP WITH THAT REASONING
THREE DOLLARS SO- I THINK WE
WANT PROVIDE THE RESOURCES- YOU
KNOW TO MEET THE NEED AND I
THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE KIND
OF A CONTINUOUS EVALUATION TO
SEE WHAT THAT NEED IS A. OKAY
SWANNANOA IF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE. AMAZING FOR A FEW
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE WINNERS AND
THE MAJORITY OF SCHOOLS ARE YOU
KNOW. THEY SEE IT AND THE OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT NOT THERE'S-
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT. YEAH
AND I THINK WE WILL DO OUR BEST
TO YOU KNOW ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO
APPLY BUT YOU KNOW AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT'S- NOT NOT A MANDATE.
DECEIT CAN YOU HELP US OUT HELP
THE PART OF FINANCE OUT HERE AND
WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU ANTICIPATE
AND THIS IS FIVE YEAR ON THE
FUNDING IN THE OUT YEARS. HOW
MANY OF OUR- SCHOOLS POVERTY
SCHOOL OF HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS
WILL HAVE. A COMMUNITY SCHOOL.
ALLOCATION TO HELP BECOME A
COMMUNITY SCHOOL IS THIS. SURE
UP I'M GONNA BE OBILE
YEAH I'M I'M GOING I'M GOING
SUGGEST THAT THE IS. IT THIS IS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT.
OBNINSK TRIPS. I HAVE- INVEST.
ARE AS I SAID MY DISTRICT IN MY
- IT. MANY OF THE- R. TRANSFORM
INITIATIVES BY HAD. WORKED ON
AND LOW WEIGHTS UP IN UP UNTIL
THIS POINT. AND- AND SO. I WILL
SAY THAT I BELIEVE THAT THESE RE
. ARE GIVEN THE STOCKS CRY. TO
IS WITH PER OR HIGHER DUPLICATE
CAL. ON IT IS CERTAINLY OUR
INTENT. DOT COM SCHOOLS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING THE GREATEST NEED.
WHERE THERE WHERE THERE IS THIS
THAT TO BE- OF WHAT WE KNOW THAT
THIS WAR WE BELIEVE. I SHOULD
SAY THAT THIS MODEL. CAN BE. WE
WOULD EXPECT THAT THE MAJORITY
OF HIGH NEED SCHOOLS AND IN OUR
STATE WILL APPLY. AND WOULD RE-
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS- FUNDING TO
SUPPORT A COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
INITIATIVE THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
HIGHS ARE. ON OUR GUYS ARE
INTENT AND NOT WILL BE ACROSS.
THANK YOU THAT WAS THE ANSWER I
WAS LOOKING FOR SO IT WON'T JUST
BE. IN A HAPHAZARD THAT A FEW OF
OUR HIGH POVERTY 80% THRESHOLD
SCHOOLS HAVE COMMUNITY SCHOOL.
BENEFITS BUT THE MAJORITY TO SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR SO
THE NEXT QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT THEY GET. THE
ADEQUATE PLANNING GRANTS AND
THEY HAVE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND WHERE WITH ALL
TO. YOU KNOW. TO BECOME A WINNER
SO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT HAPPENS FOR OUR YOU KNOW
ROUGHLY PROBABLY. FIVE THOUSAND
HIGH POVERTY- SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. SOUPS SO I THINK
THAT THE MODEL THAT WE HAVE-
THAT THAT WE HAVE THE TODAY-
WATCH OUT KIND EIGHT EIGHT DEEP
PARTNERSHIP MA- AND IN TURN OF
OUR OUTREACH AND- OF OUR ENGAGE
. I THINK WE'LL I CAN THE
INITIAL IN THE MISTER CHAIR. IS
THE PERCENTAGE OF SCHOOLS. IN
THIS INITIAL ROUND THAT QUALIFY
AT OVER EIGHTY PERCENT- AND IT
IS AS I AS I NOTED- WORK MORE
MORE LOOKING AT AT JUST OVER.
60% OF THE- OF THE SCHOOLS OF
THE INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE ALL THE
APPLICATIONS. ARE COMING IN THAT
OVER 80% DUPLICATED. WHAT THAT
INDICATES TO ME IS THAT WE HAVE
INITIAL SIGNS OF SUCCESS. IN
TERMS OF THE PROMOTION OF THIS
PROGRAM AS IN HOUSE AS AN EQUITY
DRIVEN TRANSFORMATION BOB.
PATTON DOT OUR PARTNERSHIPS BOTH
WITH L. E. AS AND COMMUNICATION
BOTH WITH ALL THE EGGS ARE. AN
WITH COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERS-
ON ON THE GROUND IN COMMUNITIES
HAS BEEN AFFECTED. WHAT WE SEE
SIGNS OF EFFECTIVENESS IN THIS
INITIAL ROUTE. WE HAVE TO BE
EQUALLY INTO I WILL SEE MORE
OPTIONS. AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
WE'VE WE'VE IN WE'VE SEEN THESE
THAT INITIAL INDICATE I. HI BOB
YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY A VISIT BY
SCHOOLS ON BOARD TO COMMUTE
SCHOOLS. THROUGHOUT THE LOS
ANGELES. ARE I'VE ALSO OUT THE
OF VISITING- VERY SUCCESSFUL
INITIAL. IN ANAHEIM YOU'RE HIGH
DISTRICT- IN ORANGE AND KNOW
THAT THERE ARE INCREDIBLE MODELS
WRITTEN SPOKE ABOUT. IT. IN HER
COMMENTS TO OAKLAND THROUGHOUT
THE DAY. WE ARE SEEING POSITIVE
FOR. AT SCHOOL SO I WEEKS TO SEE
THOSE INITIAL OFTEN POSITIVISTIC
SO IT. AROUND WHAT WE ARE GET AN
TERM OF OUR INTERVIEW TO UP HOW
ARE CHANGE AT SCHOOL SUCKS WEEKS
TO SEE. THAT CHANGE CA THROUGH
ON ITS OUTCOMES AND SO- YOUR TO
THE OF OUR WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
THAT THE- THAT THE RE GO TO
SCHOOLS WERE ARE IN INTENDED AND
THAT'S IS THERE I THINK WE TO
BUILD ON WHAT WE'VE DONE SO FAR
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO BE EVEN
ONE TOUCH. OKAY- TWO MORE TO
MARKET. SO I WOULD ASSUME THAT
OF THE SCHOOLS THE HIGH POWER
SCHOOLS THAT. THAT SOMEHOW
DIDN'T GET THEIR PLANNING GRANT
TANNER. WE DIDN'T QUITE HAPPEN
FOR THEM. IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T NEED THE RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOL BUT AS YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE BUSY TRYING TO
SURVIVE YOU THIS IS THE SAME
REASON THEY NEED A COMMUNITY
SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
TRYING TO HELP STUDENTS SUCCEED
IN SO FOCUS ON HOW ARE WE GOING
TO. IS I THINK IT WOULD BE A
TOTAL DISASTER AND AN
EMBARRASSMENT TELL YOUR FOR
CALIFORNIA IF WE HAVE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS ARE BACK HERE
RIGHT NOW WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THIS OUT 220% OF THAT HIGH
POVERTY 80% SCHOOLS YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THIS IS WHERE I PRIOR
PRIORITY. ALLOCATED A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF MONEY LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET SO HOW DO WE GO BACK AND
DOUBLE DOUBLE DOUBLE BACK WITH
THE DISTRICTS WHO WORK IN THIS
YOU KNOW ROUND ONE LESS THAN 10%
OF APPLIED SO FAR SO HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE THE
GREATEST NEED ACTUALLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BRING THIS HOME TO
THEIR DISTRICTS AND THEIR KIDS.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THANK THE
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR- I'LL I'LL
TELL YOU WHAT WE HEARING- AND
AGAIN THIS IS. AND GO. NOT I
WANT TO ON THIS. WE FROM SO JUST
. I SEVERAL I SHOULD SAY- ONLY
AIDS. THAT ARE THAT ARE VERY.
VERY INTERESTED THEY- THE
CONTENTS BENEFITS OF THE
COMMUTER SCHOOLS MODEL. BUT BUT
WHAT YOU SAID IS THIS IS JUST
OUT. ABSOLUTELY THE CASE- THIS
IS BEEN OVERWHELMING YOUR FOR
OUR SCHOOLS. THIS IS BEEN WAYS.
THE MOST DIFFICULT YEAR. AT WE
HAVE. AGAIN BECAUSE WE HAVE DONE
SO OF THAT- WE'VE BURKE THAT OUT
THAT THEY WERE ALL THE JUST OUT
THIS. TO THE THINGS ON OUR ON
THEIR PLATE EVEN IT'S COVERED
THE PRICE THAT THE IDEA IS THAT
THIS. THAT THIS WOULD BE THAT
THIS WILL PLACE PLACE SUCH A
ROLE AND HAVING SO MANY MORE
HANDS HELPING- OUT OF THE SCHOOL
SITE. BUT- BUT BUT WHAT IF THAT
TEST IS THAT THIS TIME LINE IN
YEAR AND THIS. JUST WASN'T FOR
THEM BUT THEY INTEND TO ACQUIRE.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S OUR JOB TO TURN
THE INTENTION INTO APPLICATION
INTO. IN TWO THE TYPE OF SUPPORT
THAT ACHIEVES TRANSFORMATION.
AND SO THAT'S WHERE OUR
INTENTION IS AND- MR SURE I
AGREE WITH YOU. IF WE IF WE
DON'T COME BACK AND REPORT TO
THIS COMMITTEE. ABOUT OUR
SUCCESS AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE
THAN WE CAN CLAIM NOW. THEN THAT
WOULD BE DISCUSSED BUT HI I JUST
WANT THEM TO OUR WITH THIS. WE
HAVE A LARGE AND SEE. ARE PART
AT THIS MORTGAGE. ARE COULD BASE
PARTNERS AND GREAT L. EA BY I
OWE YOU. AND OTHERS. BUT WE WANT
THE FACT. OKAY THANK YOU AND
THEN THE LAST- I READ WHEN WE
DID CAN SCHOOL. IN KNOW WHEN WAS
IT TO YEARS AGO AND IT WAS
BECAUSE- HELP START. AND I SAW
ONE IN MY NEIGHBOR HERE AND SO
THE TWO MILES FROM APPEARANCE
HOW PARK THE IS THAT HI
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AS HIGH
POVERTY. AND THEY HAD A HOW
START PROGRAM OUR NAY TO MET AT
THE. LITERALLY PORT OF THEY
BROUGH IN THE HEALTH START PRO.
REMEMBER THE- YOUNG AND PER TO
BE HEALTHY COORDINATOR HER NAME
SHE'S STILL AROUND AND ABOUT
SHE'S YOU KNOW A- IT WAS AMAZING
IT BUT NO. THREE YEARS LATER-WHATEVER WAS PULLED THE PLUG IN
IT'S NOT THERE THEN. THE TYPE
NEEDS ROOM. THE. AND THE
FAMILIES THERE YOU KNOW HAVE
TEACHERS THAT ARE HARD WORKING
THEY DON'T. THAT CONNECTS FOR
THE- HEALTH YEAH SCHOOL THAT-
EARLY AT CHILD CARE PRE PRE
AYPRO IN WHAT THIS WAS A ABOUT
. SO YOU KNOW IS THIS BE THIS
FACT WHERE THEY AND THEN IT WAS
WAS IT YEAR. YEAH THE LAST TIME
MOST YEARS US IS. FIVE YEARS SO
. HOW ARE WE GOING TO. ENSURE
THAT WHEN WE'RE ALL GONE INTO
YEARS NOW. IS A GONNA BE ANOTHER
WE'RE GONNA TRY THIS AGAIN.
BECAUSE HAVING THE I MEAN THEY
NEWS GOT THREE BILLION DOLLAR.
THE BAD NEWS IS IT'S YOU KNOW
NOW AN ONGOING THING. SELL I
KNOW IT WAS WE HAD LAST YEAR-
AMAZING- SURGEON ONE TIME
REVENUE. FRANKLY WE HAD TO SPEND
IT. AND THIS WAS LIKE HOOKED UP
WITH A LIST OF THINGS WERE TO
SPEND ONE TIME MONEY AND THIS
WAS ALWAYS HIGH ANALYSTS- WITH
BUTTER HERE SO IT'S A GOOD THING
TO SPEND MONEY ON. BUT HOW DO WE
ENSURE. THAT YOU KNOW ALL THIS
EFFORTS- MEETS THE TEST OF TIME
AND COULD BE CONTINUED. AND
SERVE THE KIDS AND THE FAMILIES.
IN THESE COMMITTEE SCHOOLS. SO
WHO WANTS TO TAKE A AT THAT- I
PUBLISHER WITH OF MINE. AND THE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM ALREADY
INCORPORATES MANY OF THE
STRATEGIES FROM THE HEALTHY
START INITIATIVE- AND AS
MENTIONED WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF A COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS TO BE ENGAGING IN
SUSTAINABILITY AND COORDINATION
WORK FROM DAY ONE FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE GRANT PERIOD
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD. IN ORDER
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
SUCCESSFUL PLAN TO FIFTEEN
ONGOING PROGRAMMING SO A WEEK
BACK ENTITY SHOULD BE USING
GRANT FUNDING TO BUILD THOSE
STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THAT SUPPORT THE
ONGOING WORK AND ALSO TO
IDENTIFY AND FREE TO GATHER THE
OTHER SOURCES OF ON GOING
FUNDING FROM THE STATE SUCH AS
THAT YOU LOOK AT EXPANDING
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
UNIVERSAL INSTRUCTION
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN STATE
PRESCHOOL OR BY DRAWING DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS FROM ELLIE A
MEDICAL. BILLING OPTIONS PROGRAM
. SO THAT HELPS TODAY BUT HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT AFTER FIVE YEARS
THAT. THESE ENTITIES STILL HAVE
THE TOOLS TO CONTINUE THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS WHEN THE WHEN THE
ONE TIME MONEY FADES AWAY. YEAH
I THINK SO WITH THAT AND- MR
VIDMAR HAD MENTIONED THERE IS
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL THAT'S
PROVIDED TO THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS PROGRAM THOUGHT COVER
COMING SO THEY WILL BE GETTING
THE SUPPORT. AND THERE'S ALSO
THE FORMATIVE EVALUATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
THE QUALIFIED AT THE QUALIFIED
ENTITIES THAT ARE SUPPORTING
COMMUNITIES. ARE ALSO EVALUATING
AND CONTINUOUSLY EVALUATING THE
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE IMPLEMENTING IMPLEMENTING A
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN OR FIGURING
OUT HOW TO BRING TOGETHER THESE
DIFFERENT SOURCES OF ON GOING
FUNDING STREAMS- AND THERE IS
NOT FUNDING THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND QUALIFIED AND IF
YOU FOR COORDINATION. AND SO WE
THINK THAT ALL OF THESE-
COMPONENTS WILL HELP TO MAKE
SURE THAT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WILL
BE SUSTAINABLE. YES- MY
UNDERSTANDING IN IN PLAIN
ENGLISH IS THESE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS WOULD HAVE LIKE. A
COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER SCHOOL AND THAT MEANS TO
PEOPLE SO IT'S A YOU TO PEEP HOW
YOU TO IN THE ARE WORKING AT AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER HERE- LAND ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL CREDIT RIGHT A MILE FROM
. AND YOUR JOB IS TO DRAW IN
RESOURCE FROM COUNTY FEDERAL FOR
HEALTH CARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH MEDIC HOW YOU KNOW
AFTER SCHOOL LIKE DRAW IN SEE
LIKE- YOU KNOW A CONVENER MAVEN
TO G. LIKE HELP MAKE SURE YOU'RE
COORDINATING BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THE SCHOOL I WANT TO DO THAT
STUFF BUT THEY HAVE TO FOCUS ON.
TEACHNG CLASSROOMS. DEALING
WITH YOU KNOW COUNTING THAT
THAT'S NOT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TIME TO DO THAT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING SO IN FIVE YEARS YOU
BRING AND ALL THIS STUFF. AND
THEN THIS MONEY GOES AWAY AND
YOU TWO ARE THERE THAT. SCHOOL
SITE ANYMORE. AND THEN. THAT THE
EVERYTHING KIND OF YOU KNOW.
MAYBE FADES AWAY SO HOW DO WE-
IN THE SIDE I GET A YOU'RE
SAYING THAT TACKLE THAT'S WHY
TIME BUT AFTER THAT STAFFING OF
THE POSITIONS EXPIRES. THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED WITH HEALTHY START
. IT JUST AT THIS TIME THAT THE
YEAR AFTER LISTER BUT LAUGHED IT
WAS STILL THERE. BARELY TWO
YEARS KIND OF THREE YEARS FOUR
YEARS IT AS ALL GONE SO HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE. THAT THE LIKE YOU
KNOW. AT THAT SOMEONE WHO'S
WHO'S CARING FOR A GARDEN AFTER
A WHILE SO IT'S NOT THERE
ANYMORE. IT DOESN'T LOOK THE
SAME. YEAH I THINK THE GOAL IS
TO- ESTABLISHED IN FIFTY TWO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL OF PROGRAMMING IN THE
SCHOOL ALSO UTILIZING OTHER
SOURCES OF ON GOING FUNDING- TO
KEEP THE COORDINATE. AROUND OR
POTENTIALLY TRAIN- AND A STAFF
MEMBER THAT'S ALREADY THERE TO
CONTINUE THOSE SERVICES AND
THAT'S THAT YEAH THAT WOULD BE
THAT- INTENT OF- AT THE FUNDING
FOR THESE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
CRACK AND TO SUPPORT THE ONGOING
FIFTEEN OF THE PROGRAM OKAY
THANK YOU FINAL QUESTION. AS
WELL AND WHICH FURTHER QUESTIONS
SAYING NINE WE WILL I HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN FOR THE MAY REVISED
THANK YOU FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION WE HAVE NEXT TO VOTE
ONLY AGENDA ITEM AND TWELVE WE
HAVE SOME VARIAS- NON
CONTROVERSIAL PROPOSALS THAT-
BOTH CAUCUSES- ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SO. LOOKING FOR. A MOTION-
LOOK MOTION BY DOCTOR CHOI
SECOND BY- SOME MEMBER OF ON THE
WHOLE SLATE OF I WANT TO
FIFTEEN- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HI. CHOI PLEASE MEDINA
O'DONNELL. REYES WELL. FONG I
OKAY THAT THOSE THAT- THOSE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH FIFTEEN PASS
FOUR ZERO I WITH THAT WE WILL
PROCEED NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
IF YOU HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
TODAY. IN THE ROOM YEAH. SEEING
NONE IN THE AUDIENCE OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE LINE. HEARING NONE. A PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THAT ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL
GO TO LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SH GOOD MORNING THAT
HOLLOW LANE HAVE HAD BACK. OTHER
COMMUNITY SCHOOL PARTNER PROGRAM
HOLD GREAT TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR VULNERABLE AND FAMILIES WE
NOW THAT THE EARLIER OF A
CHILD'S LIFE SOME OF THE MOST
CRITICAL. AN INVESTMENT DURING
THE TIME A VERY HIGH RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR THIS REASON
LEGISLATION OPERATE THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL. PROGRAM CALL
OUT EARLY LEARNING PART AND HOW
START PROGRAM FOR PARTNERSHIPS
WITH SCHOOLS. THAT BEING THAT
PRINTABLE IMPLEMENT OF THE
COMMUNITY FOR PARTNERS PROGRAM
HAD NOT WORKED INTEGRATE LAW
PARTNER THAT'S MANY PARTNERS.
HERE'S THAT NO OUT REACHED EARLY
LEARNING PARTNERS BACK SAID AN
ALLIGATOR KNOCKING GUIDANCE THE
RECOMMEND. TO OUT TO EARLY
PARTNER. ACCORDING HAD HER HELP
RICH WHICH- NEARLY A AND FIFTY
HAD POGRAMS THE- WITH. PROVIDE
ANY. ABOUT THE- SCHOOL PROGRAM.
THAT IS A- HAD THEIR OPERATE
COMPREHENSIVE FULL TILED FULL
FAN SERVICES MAKE THEM IDEAL FOR
CAN. CAN SCHOOL PROGRAM. GOING
WE HELP THAT THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL
PROACTIVELY. A PLAN TO GUIDE
ELEAZAR INTEGRATING EASY AND
MANY VEHICLE MODELS AND CONDUCT
OUTREACH TO THE- COMMUNITY. AS
WELL AS A AFFILIATED EARLY IN
PROGRAM INCLUDING HEAD START
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND JUST A
REMINDER ONE MINUTE OR LESS
PLEASE. ONE MIN OR LESS NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WELCOME FROM MINE A LOT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ERIN APTIOM
HAVE A PUBLIC AND HELPING
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE FUTURE OF
LEARNING WITH SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY WHAT THE KIND OF THE
INTER. CHANGES INCLUDING FOR A
APARTMENT. THE STATE CORRECT
GOING TO SENIOR REPORT IMPROPER
PRESS THEIR TO SCHOOL PLAN
INCLUDING THE THEN OUT COMES
FROM THE- YEAR. AT THIS CLUB BY
THE END OF LEVEL MAKE THESE
MATERIALS PART OF THE ENOUGH
PROGRESS ARE. THAT MINISTER
DEPARTMENT TERMINAL. CHECK THE
MAKING OF THE COURT AND AT.
SCHOOL I'M SUGGEST ADDING A
GRANT PRIORITY FOR OUR- RT HAVE
A PLAY TO CREATE MULTI. TEAM
THAT INCLUDES STUDENTS FAMILIES
EDUCATORS COMMUNITY BASED MARKET
. WE BELIEVE. OUR TECHNICAL TEAM
THAT INCLUDE COMMUNITY ARE AT
THE BOB HELP ENSURE PRO. THE
STATE ABILITY. NOTHING I CAN
PAYER TO APPLE TO COMMIT TO FIND
RACIALLY JEFF THE RESTORED.
TO HELP SUPPORT COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS TO BE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGEMENT INNOVATION IN MY
CEMEX INFRASTRUCTURE EXPANSION
ON THE GROUND TO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS TO PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
USE THAT THE HIGHER DEDICATED
CHANGE BACK INTO ACTIVE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING TURN MEMBERS STAFF NOW
ON CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS ANY
SCHOOL TODAY WE NOW COMMUNITIES
PRO BASS HAVE DESIGN PROGRAMS
THAT MEET THEIR OWN CHALLENGES
AND PRIORITIES. ME BATES
APPROACHES TO TRAUMA INFORMED
MENTAL HEALTH AND SCHOOL CLIMATE
SHOULD BE THE CORNERSTONE OF
EVERY SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
GRANT. THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND
THAT ALL COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AT
THE SIDE INCREASING TRAUMA
INFORMED MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS. REDUCING POLICING
CENTER AND BOTH OF THEM FOR YOU
THINK UNICAL INCREASED SERVICES
AND SUPPORT INCLUDING.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES.
HE TO BUILD HEALTH KIDNEY. AND
SAY- NOT OF TO DECATUR EIGHTY
SET. ABOUT THE COLLAB WITH
COMMUNITY BASED EXPERT DESIGNED
TO INFORMED INPUT SCHOOL AND
REDUCTION OF DRIVE AND- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
THANK YOU COME FROM FOR YEAR IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR NUMBER
MY NAME IS DR HEY AND I'M
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
LEARNING EXCHANGE WHERE
STATEWIDE PARTNERSHIP CONSORTIUM
OF COMMUNITY SCHOOL
PRACTITIONERS RESEARCHERS AND
POLICY INFLUENCERS. WORKING TO
STRENGTHEN HIGH QUALITY
IMPLEMENTATION OF SCHOOL CHILD
APPROACHES TO TEACHING AND
LEARNING I WANTED TO EMPHASIZE
THE POINT THAT MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S REYES A MEMBER
MCCARTY ALLUDED TO IN TERMS OF
SUSTAINABILITY SCALE AND IMPACT.
THE CAMPUS DEAN ABILITY OF THESE
STRATEGIES ARE DISTANCED
CHALLENGE NOT ONE OF COMPETITION
OR BLENDING AND BRAIDING FUNDING
THIS IS ABOUT THE CORE MISSION
OF ALL TO EDUCATE STUDENTS FOR
THE WHOLE TRIAL FINDS A BURNING
AND DEVELOPMENT. AND AS SUCH WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE LONG TERM
SYSTEMIC BUDGET GAP SPACING
EDUCATION ONE TIME RECOVERY
DOLLARS ARE ON GOING LIMITED
AMOUNTS OF TARGETED GRANT
FUNDING WILL NOT RESULT IN
SUCCESSFUL HEALING CENTER
COMMUNITY SCHOOL STRATEGIES. ARE
ELEAZAR FACING MASSIVE NEXT
EXPONENTIALLY GROWING DEFICITS
DUE TO PENSION LIABILITIES THAT
ROADING PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURES
PHYSICAL CLASS. TEACHER
SHORTAGES. CHINA ENROLLMENT AND
IN. PROGRAM SUCH AS SPECIALIZED
. ADDRESS THESE MASS STRUCTURAL
AND- MAKE THAT MORE. THAT SCHOOL
AND DISTRICTS WILL BE ABLE TO
INVEST SHORT TERM DOLLARS TO
CREATE THE SYSTEMS AND MUSCLES
OF PARTNERSHIPS NEEDED TO CREATE
AND SUSTAIN COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
FOR ALL SCHOOLS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR NEXT QUESTION. WE WERE BOTH
THE LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THANK YOU- CARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PETE
BONTA PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
UNITED WAY THE CALIFORNIA. WE
CALIFORNIA SPONSORED AB HELLO
SEVEN TO HELP YOU START BILL THE
PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS LAST YEAR'S
EIGHTY ONE FOUR VERY EITHER
REPORTER BUT IT DIED MODELING
HEALTHY STAR PROGRAM WHICH THE
DECREASE IS THE MATH AND READNG
SCORES AND 50% YOUR ACT THE
HEALTHCARE IT ALSO PAID FOR
ITSELF AT THE START BABIC DEF.
EVERYONE DOLLAR IT STATE HEALTHY
START THEY NEVER BOARD OUT NOW
THE WHITE I'M LOCAL FUNDS.
PEOPLE OF THE CODE THAT MARK.
WORK CHOIR AND THAT'S IS. THE
KEY FEATURES OF THE HEALTH CARE. AND WE MCCARTY COUNTY TO
ASSURE ONE TRUE COMMUNITY IN. TO
A LENGTHY WE- RIDER AT FACT AT
THE PROGRAM ISN'T. OTHER
CONCRETE FOR STRONGLY THE MEDIA
DEPARTMENT. SYSTEM LOS FAMILY
THE PARTNERS THANK HEARING
REPRESENTS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
PEOPLE. TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
THE COMMITTEES WATER HEARD BY
SURELY PLAN I ROLE IN PROGRAM IT
BEST FOR THEM. WITH FORWARD TO
WORK WITH DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
THE LESS. TO MAKE IT PROGRAM
THIS YEAH THANKS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.